[موسيقى]
مساء الخير حلقتنا النهارده عن الاقتصاد
الازرق ما هو الاقتصاد الازرق من هم رواد
واباطرة ولماذا اخفقت دول اخرى للاجابه عن
كل هذه الاسئله انا بستيف اليوم
مجددا ضيفنا الخبير الملاحه البحريه
المهندس وائل الدور وعضو مجلس اداره قناه
السويس السابق مساء الخير باش مالس مساء
النور يا سعيد باشا هل ممكن تدينا اجابه
سريعه لما هو ما هو الاقتصاد الازرق
ببساطه كل الانشطه الاقتصاديه المتعلقه
بالبحار والمحيطات
والانهار فبت
خش مجموعه كبيره جدا من هذه الانشطه زي
التجاره والنقل
بالسب زي
استكشاف الغاز والبترول من البحار
النهارده
2% من الغاز والبترول اللي انت بتستخدمه
طالع من البحار واخد
بالك مزارع صيد السمك
النهارده الصاد الازرق بيوفر
لمليار فرد في العالم بروتين اللي هو
السمك واح ب سيادتك بيتيجي
كذلك عمليه الطاقه من البحار سواء طاقه
الرياح ومزارع الرياح او الطاقه من الموج
واخد بالك وحركه المد والجذر كل دي ثروات
في البخار تقدر الثروات الاقتصاد الازرق ب
24 ترليون دولار هناك بعض الدول نجحه في
الاقتصاد الازرق يعني لو جبنا مثلا الناتج
القومي لدوله زي فيتنام معتمده 30% من
الناتج القومي على الاقتصاد
الازرق دوله زي ماليزيا
22% دوله زي اندونيسيا
20% دوله زي الصين حجم الاقتصاد الازرق
سنه
2014 كان 960 مليار دولار خلق
4 مليون فرصه عمل
ا دوله زي سنغافور 7% من الناتج القومي
بتاعها يعتمد على الاقتصاد الازرق وهكذا
طيب انا عرفت من حضرتك يعني مش من حد تاني
انه في دول بعينها وفي المنطقه تحديدا
استطاعت ان هي
يعني تمضي قدما بخطه سريعه جدا في
الاقتصاد الازرق بينما دول المنطقه شبه
نائمه يعني وهذه الدوله تحديدا هي اسرائيل
ممكن تحدثنا عن تجربه اسرائيل في استغلال
الاقتصاد
الازرق
اسرائيل من الدول اللي عندها
استراتيجيه
ل المرين استراتيجي من احسن الاستراتيجيات
اللي اتعملت
اللي عملها
28 عالم وخبير
ومتخصص في مجالات البحريه المختلفه
والسكيورتي
والمواني والاحياء المائيه والاسماك وكل
ما يتعلق بهذا وهذه المجموعه اشتغلت
تحت اشراف خبراء عالميين من العالم كله هم
سبعه ثلاثه من المانيا واثنين من امريكا
وواد من فرنسا وواحد من انجلترا ال 28
الاوليين كانوا
اسرائيليين الاول دول ال 28 كلهم من داخل
اسرائيل السبعه دول زي بورد استشاري
للمجموعه اللي بتعمل المخطط المارين بلان
بتاع اسرائيل اول حاجه
حددت الحيز البحري بتاعها هي بدات امتى يا
باشمهندس
ديت تقريبا بدات
في 2013 لا يعني مش 2015 كان خلصت كله
فحددت المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخاصه بها
ف رسمت هذه المنطقه لقت مساحتها عباره عن
6000 ك مر
مربع دي اكبر من مساحه ارض اسرائيل الحالي
اللي هي حدودها القانونيه و مستوطناتها
على حساب الاراضي الفلسطينيه لهم حوالي
ايه 22 مثلا
22400 اه كيل متر مربع
فاذا المساحه دي هي اللي هتستخدمها في
المستقبل فيها ثروات كبيره جدا زي الغاز
وال الاكتشافات اللي اكتشافاته
فيها ابتدت
بال سيادتك تحدد الاستخدامات المختلفه
لهذا الحيز
البحري انا هستخدمه في ايه ايه الانشطه
المختلفه يعني لو هعمل مثلا محطات تحليه
ماقدرش اعمل هذه المحطات وجنبها ايه بصرف
صرف
صحي يبقى في تعارض بين الانشطه
فعملت دراسه لكل الانشطه البحريه اللي مم
ممكن تقوم بها ايه اللي
ممكن يتكامل مع بعض ايه اللي عاوز تنسيق
مع بعض واخد بالك ايه اللي بيتعارض مع
بعض استخدمت بقى الشاطق بتاعها محدود كله
194 كيلو الشاطق بتاعها فلازم استخداماته
دي مهمه جدا بجانب ان عندها تراث واثار
غارقه لان شرق البحر الابيض مهد للحضارات
القديمه ففي مواني غرقانه في حاجات غرقانه
ف يحافظ على هذا
الكلام ابتدت تخطط هذا الساحل هنا هنعمل
مواني هنا قاعده بحريه هنا نشاط سياحي هنا
تحليات ميه هنا باور ستيشن و كذا كذا كذا
بحيث ما يترش زي ما قلنا
هذا هذا المخطط يعتبر من احسن المخططات
اللي اتعمل في هذا
المجال عالميا ولا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
انا اعتقد على مستوى العالم من احسن ما
يمكن اللي عملوه
ده بعد
كده هي في دوله اسرائيل جيرانها مش
قابلناها مافيش كذا ف مديه برض او وويه
كبيره جدا لاعمال الدفاع
فواخر اعمال الدفاع فهي حطت 12 هدف وهي
بترسم هذه
الاستراتيجيه كذلك ان 12 هدف تحققهم من
هذه الاسترا من هذه المنطقه بد منها اهداف
اقتصاديه مختلفه ومنها هدف بتقول حركه
دفاع ان هي تعزز دفاعاتها مثلا في بالضبط
بالضبط فتيجي
ايه
تجد الغاز عندها ابار غاز سواء في
ليبيتين او حقل تمار او تمار دول اكبر
حقلين غاز اكبر حقلين غاز في مياه اسرائيل
الاقتصاديه هتلاقي جنبهم على طول حقل ظهر
المصري وجنبهم في قبرص افروديت اه مضبوط
كلهم جنب بعض المنطقه دي كذلك حد اماكن
هعمل ايه مصايد للسمك ومزارع سمكيه
والرخويات هعمل فين مزارع للطحالب عشان
استنتج الوقود الحيوي واخد بالك فهي حددت
الاستخدامات
المختلفه يعني برضو هتنشر صناعيه لان انت
عندك مطار بن
جوريون عشان التوسعات بتاعته مافيش مكان
بعد 20 30
ممكن يبقى الحيز البحري ده امتداد المطار
هينش فيه عن طريق عمل جزر صناعيه وهكذا
اذا هي شافت ايه احتياجاتها وايه تطورها
واهتمت كذلك بالموانئ المستقبليه لهذه
هتتوسخ ازاي وايه الاماكن كذا القواعد
البحريه بتاعتها هتبقى فين وفين محطات
التحليه الانشطه الرياضيه فين واخد بال
سيادتك ما سبتش نشاط ما دخلتو في الاعتبار
وهذه الاستراتيجيه بتراجع بصفه دوريه مع
التقدم العلمي والتغيرات الجو سياسيه اللي
بتحصل في المنطقه فهي تمتلك اقتصاديه ا
يعني استراتيجيه جيده لاستغلال الحايز
البحري
لها وانا بس اسال حضك سؤال وملحوظه لان
دايما كل من يسمع اي شيء عن اسرائيل دايما
بيبقى مستقر في ذهنه انها سطت على حقوق
الاخرين
ا عند عند يعني تخطيطها لاي شيء بتقول
عليه اسرائيلي سؤالي هنا هي فيما يتعلق
بالاراضي الفلسطينيه الضفه الغربيه
بالكامل حتى لو الفلسطينيين خدوها لا تطل
على البحر المتوسط يتبقى غزه هل هي سطت
على
حقوق الاطلاله غزه يعني المنطقه البحريه
لغزه ولا
استبعدتها هي مستبعدا حاليا لان عليها
خلاف اقليم محتل غزه واخد بال سيادتك انما
في نفس الوقت في هي مرسمتش الحدود غير مع
دوله واحده بس اللي هي قبرس قبرس هناك برض
خلاف في ترسيم الحدود مع لبنان هي رسمت
يعني مع قسمت اخيرا
اتفق على ايه ترسيم بس ما وقعو اتفاقيات
اه اه هو بالشكل اللي حراك بتقول عليه يا
باشمهندس ده معناها انه يعني اسرائيل
باستخدام او بقياده 35 عالم نجحت في ان هي
تعمل اسرائيل جديده احنا بنتكلم على 26000
كل م مربع يعني بالضبط وشكل كف بالضبط كده
بتحاول تستغله امس الاستغلال لما نيجي
نمسك التخطيط الحيز البحري هنلاقيه بيمر
باربع مراحل اول حاجه
بتجمع كل المعلومات عن المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخاصه لك واخد بال سيادتك وبتحل هذه
المعلومات بعد كده بتحدد الرؤيه والاهداف
اللي انت عاوزها من منطقه الحايز البحري
بتاعك بعد كده بتحط سيناريوهات مختلفه
لتنفيذ
هذه استقريت على هذا الكلام بتعمل
الاستراتيجيه بتاعتك وبتراجع بصفه دوريه
طبقا للمتغيرات اللي بتحصل في العلم
والظروف
المختلفه اسرائيل عملت كده بالف اسرائيل
عملت كده فهي ايه حطت اهداف اولا تحسين
داره الحيز البحري استخدمه بنوع من الرشد
والعقلانيه
ا بتطيح المعلومات عن الحيز البحري الخاص
بها
للعامه عندها قاعده بيانات اي حد يقدر يخش
عليها كده بتحافظ على البيئه البحريه
والتراث بتاعها واخد
بالك بتطور موارد الطاقه بتاعتها وخصوصا
اعبار الغاز اللي اكتشفتها بطريقه
عقيمه فيها من الحكمه والحذر عشان تستمر
اطول مده في استغلالها طريقه حكيمه اه
بخلاف كذلك بتطور موانيها النقل البحري
والتجاره واسطول واخد بالك بتطور اسطول
الصيد بتاعها والمزارع
السمكيه
بتستخدم الحيز البح
للتوسعات زي ما قلنا الارض بتاعتها محدوده
جدا فيهم انها تستخدم هذا الحيز في
التوسعات
العمرانيه وبتعتبر ان الحيز البحري ده
هو الجسر اللي بيربطها مع العالم كله لان
تجارتها 98% بتيجي من البحر ده الاسباب
الرئيسيه اللي عملت عليها الاستراتيجيه
بتاعتها اسرائيل طب اذا في ح حضرتك تحب
تضيف حاجه بالنسبه لاسرائيل ولا كده
الصوره اكتملت كده مت الصوره واضحه الصوره
اكتملت بس اسرائيل في النهايه بنتكلم على
ساحل حوالي 194 ك مت احنا عندنا دول
المنطقه عندها اطلالات اكبر بكتير جدا هل
ممكن نقارن مثلا اسرائيل بدول ثانيه مثلا
مثلا احنا احنا مين ب احنا مصر مثلا مصر
مصر عندنا اطلالات على البحر الاحمر
والبحر الابيض تقريبا 6000 كيلو اه مساحه
الحيز البحري بتاعنا او المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخاصه بتاعتنا
264000 ك م مربع يعني ربع مساحه الارض
المصريه احنا مليون كيلو دول 264 اكتر من
ربع بحاجه بسيطه
واح طبعا ال 264000 ك م مربع اضعاف ال
266000 ك مر مربع البحريه الاسرائيليه 10
مرات انما اح احنا ما عندناش استراتيجيه
ولا رؤيه للحيز البحري واستخداماته ودي من
اخطر الحاجات واخد بالك يعني ممكن اعمل
نشاط يتعارض مع نشاط وانت تعلم ان احنا في
المياه بتاعتنا في الحيز البحري بتاعنا
عندنا استكشافات للغاز
والبترول كتيره جدا هنشا في المستقبل
محطات لتوليد الطاقه من الرياح واخد بالك
فكل ده لازم يبقى فيه مخطط ومست بلان
للحيز البحري بتاعك وايه الانشطه اللي انت
هتزاول المدن الساحليه الانشطه الشاطئيه
هتبقى شكلها ايه مزارع السمكيه هتبقى فين
المواني الجديده اللي انت بتنش هتبقى فين
تاثير المناخ والتغيرات المناخيه هتحمي
ازاي كل ده لازم تحطه في الاستراتيجيه
بتاعتك طب هي في جمله او جملتين مصر ما
قطعت اي شوط يذكر يعني في استغلال
الاقتصاد
الازرق احنا عندنا استغلال لبعض انواع
الاقتصاد الازرق بس ما فيش رؤيه شامله ولا
مخطط شامل متكامل للاستغلال
هذاه يعني انت بتستغل مثلا مصيط بتطلع
تصطاد من البحر عامل ايه مزارع سمكيه واخد
بالك عندك ابار
من البحر واخد بالك ها عندك مواني ونقل
بحري والكلام ما انت انما لازم يبقى عندك
مصدر او مخطط عام واستراتيجيه رئيسيه عشان
ما يحصلش تعارض بين الانشطه المختلفه عشان
تعظم الفائده وتعظم الفائده اللي انت
عاوزها من الحيز بتاعك هو قبل ما اسال
حضرتك انا عرفت من حضرتك انه يعني مساهمه
الانشطه البحريه ا بالنسبه للاقتصاد
المصري حوالي ا 2.5% هو ما فيش رقم دكير
جدا انما يقدر ب
2.2% ليه لانك ما عندكش قاعده
بيانات يعني عشان تجمع تلاق مثلا
احصائيات وزاره الزراعه هتديك السمك اللي
انت بتصطاد فيه طيب ايه لو عندك مثلا
مزارع للطحالب والكلام ده فين ما فيش
بيانات عنها وهكذا فانت محتاج قاعده
بيانات وتجمع هذه البيانات وتحللها ودائما
تطورها وتخليها متاحه لكل واحد انا راجل
مستثمر يبقى شايف في المنطقه دي بوتنشل
كذا اقدر اجي اعمل مشروع فان ما عندكش هذا
طب اذا تركنا مصر وخدنا وسالت حضرتك انجح
دوله في المنطقه خلاف اسرائيل في استغلال
الاقتصاد الازرق والانشطه البحريه
المختلفه المغرب المغرب المغرب عندها
استراتيجيه للبلو ايكونومي وعندها مارين
بلان لها والمغرب ماشي بخطوات جيده جدا في
هذا المجال هي عندها اطلاله هايله طبعا
على المتوسط وعلى الاطلنتي بالظبط كده
وعندها انشطه صي بس انا كان انطباعي ان
انا من متابعتي للاقتصاد الاماراتي ان هي
بالغت الاهتمام بالاقتصاد الازرق من خلال
اداره المواني في سواء في حدودها او في كل
دول العالم
يعني نسبه الاقتصاد
الازرق في الامارات بتوصل
4.1% من الناتج القومي بتاعهم وهي
عندها مواني دبي دي شركه عالميه بتدير 50
محطه حاويات في مختلف بلاد العالم فدي
حاجه كويسه جدا فانت برض لازم يبقى عندك
شركات لاداره اي بلد تسع ذك محطات وهكذا
وانت دوله عريقه في البحر المفروض يبقى لك
دور في
هذا عظيم جدا ا هل مثلا في دول ثانيه في
المنطقه بدات ان هي تهتم باقتصادها الازرق
اكتر دوله طبعا فيها احصائيات جيده جدا
للاقتصاد الازرق واستخداماته وكده هو
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني
الاقتصاد الازرق ده خلق 5 مليون فرصه عمل
منه 5 مليون فرصه عمل بالنسبه لدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اللي هم 500 مليون مش
كتير قوي يعني بس بالنسبه لان هو برده
داخله من الاقتصاد الازرق كله لو جيناك
كده هتلاقيه 4 ونص 5% لان هو عنده انشطه
اخرى وفي دول كثيره حبيسه في النص اوروبا
اه صحيح واخد بالك انما انا بتكلم بصفه
عامه كاتحاد
اوروبي فتلاقي قاعده البيانات بتاعته
محدثه ومتاحه لاي حد يقدر يخش
يجيب البيانات بتاعته حجم التجاره
العالميه بتاعته الاسطول بتاعه الانشطه
بون واصلاحات السفن م اكثر دول العالم
حضرتك بترا اكثر دول العالم اهتماما
واستغلالا
ل الثروات البحريه ليها
ا يعني الطاله حاليا طبعا اليابان كانت من
الدول الممتازه في استغلال ثرواتها
البحريه الدول الطالعه الناميه النهارده
بنيام بيمثل الاقتصاد الازرق 30% من
ناتج القومي بتاعها كذلك فيتنام طلع طلع
يعني النهارده فيتنام سادس دوله في العالم
في بون السفن واخد بال سيادتك فيتنام زي
ما كلنا نعلم ادمرت بالكامل في حرب دوس مع
امريكا وتكسرت كل حاجه بعد الحرب ابتدت
النهضه بتاعتها مشيت على خطوات رشيده
الرؤيه بتاعتها واضحه اهتمت بالتعليم
ومراكز التدريب بحيث العماله عندها توصل
للمستوى العالمي وتستطيع انها تشتغل في اي
مكان في العالم فانت محتاج حاجه زي كده
محتاج تدرس
هذه التجربه في فيتنام وازاي بهذه السرعه
يوصلوا لهذه المعدلات يعني الدوله اللي
عاوزه تتمي قدرتها في الاقتصاد الازرق
عندها تجارب معينه يمكن ان ترصدها زي
تجربه فيتنام بالط بالضبط وممكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي يساعدك ويعمل
لك يعني استراتيجيه للبلو ايكونومي لان هو
عنده مبادره
للاقتصاد الازرق لحوض البحر الابيض كله
فانت جز جزء من هذا الحوط واخد بالك فممكن
بالتعاون معاه تعمل استراتيجيه وتخطط
الحاز البحري والمنطقه الاقتصاديه الخاصه
لك في الانشطه المختلفه بحيث لا تتعارض
انما تتكامل مع بعض حضرتك ك خبير وبترس
التجارب المختلفه على مدار عشرات السنوات
يعني ايه اهم القواسم المشتركه بين
التجارب الناجحه اسرائيل فيتنام اليابان
دي تجارب ناجحه
التعليم اساسا التعليم حاجه مهمه جدا
والصح واخد بالك وبعدين العلم بيتطور
بسرعه فلازم انت تبقى متطور مع هذا وتهتم
بالتعليم يعني بدون التعليم عمره ما هيبقى
عندك نهضه ولا اقتصاد ازرق ولا غير اقتصاد
اخضر التعليم رقم واحد رقم واحد ايه
الحاجه اللي ممكن يمثلها
تجربه اسرائيل من خطر على دول الجوار هي
نمت ونجحت وعامله كده زي ما بتعمل في
مجالات تانيه
كتير هدفها الاساسي انها تقود المنطقه
كلها واد بالك وزي ما شفنا مبادره الممر
الاقتصادي بتاع الهند هي عاوزه تندمج في
المنطقه وتقود المنطقه في كل الانشطه
وعندهم مستوى تقدم من الذكاء الصناعي
والهاي تيك والكلام من ده وبعض الدول
العربيه بتبهر من هذا وبتمشي ورا هذا
الكلام اسرائيل عندها مراكز بحثيه جيده
جدا واخد بالك لما تطلع
على معظم اللي
بينشرو بالعبري انما ممكن تطلع برض على
بعض الابحاث اللي
عندهم الكذا بتلاقي بيعملوا ابحاث جيده
جدا في دوله يفترض ان كان يبقى ليها وده
السؤال الاخير لحضرتك
يعني يفترض ان عندها امكانيات ضخمه جدا
ولكن بحكم ظروفها التعيسه فهي مستبعده وهي
اليمن اظن ان اليمن لو خدت فرصتها من
الاستثمار ممكن تتغير خريطه اليمن وخريطه
المنطقه بسبب ما يحدث في اليمن انا اتفق
معاك اليمن عندها ثوره ثروه من البترول
وال
والشواطئ بتاعتها من اغنى الشواطئ في
الاسماك والنوعيات المفتخر من الاسماك
انما نتيجه والموانئ عندها موان طبيه طب
والموانئ وعندها ممر مهم جدا باب المندب
اه طبعا ده ممكن يقفل البحر الاحمر اه
طبعا واد بالك اذا نتيجه عدم الاستقرار في
اليمن والحروب
و ضيع عل هي كل هذه الفرص ضعط فرص
ضائعه
فاليمن عندها بوتنشال كبير جدا للتقدم بس
لو حصل فيه نوع من الاستقرار الابتي
والكلام ده جزيل الشكر باشمهندس العاف
ربنا يخلي حضرتك الله يميك